Speaker 1: And speaking of horrible narratives,
Donald Trump has been out there over the last
few days scribbling down his little idiotic, you
know, statements as fast as he can, having his
spokeswoman, Liz Harington, tweet them out. And of
course, most of them have been about Afghanistan,
you know, trying to lay all of this
squarely at the feet of Joe Biden.
But in one of his statements about the Reid. He
actually said something else, he blamed Biden
for another surrender, not just allegedly
surrendering to the Taliban. Here it is.
First, Joe Biden surrendered to covid and it's
come roaring back then he surrendered to the
Taliban, who has quickly overtaken Afghanistan
and destroyed confidence in American power and
influence. The outcome in Afghanistan, including
the withdrawal, would have been totally different
if the Trump administration had been in charge.
Who or what will Joe Biden surrender to next?
Someone should ask him if they can find him.
Yeah, says the guy that spent like 25 percent of
his presidency not at the White House. If they can
find him or we know where to find you, golf dude,
you're probably hitting the links somewhere,
right? Actually, you're probably sitting in
a dark room just scribbling these things out
as fast as you can. Like, let's get this out
now. I've addressed the Afghanistan
stuff, but surrendering to covid.
That's just plain idiotic. I don't get me wrong.
I have not been shy about criticizing the Biden
administration when they deserve to be criticized.
It's what I do when I'm not going to stop doing
that. But their response to covid no, I'm sorry,
that's not something that I've criticized because
they've done a pretty darn good job. Have they
been perfect? No, there's a couple of things
they've done or said that I've disagreed with.
For example, you know, when they first came
out, said, we're going to get all the kids
back in school, I thought at the time, you know
what, it's a little too soon. And hey, of course,
look where we're at now. But to say he surrendered
to covid. This coming from the guy that once told
people to inject bleach coming from the
same guy who said we'd have zero cases
by April 20, 20, that we would be reopened by
Easter of 20, 20. The guy who downplayed the
pandemic every possible chance he got accusing
another person of surrendering to the virus.
That's just plain nuts. And here's the thing,
yeah, we got a surge of covid in this country.
But in no way is that Joe Biden's fault.
No way at all. I'm sorry, but it's not.
The fault right now lies with the anti maskers,
it lies with the anti taxers, and of course,
it lies with any governor, regardless of party,
that is not allowing their cities or school
districts to implement mask mandates.
And actually, all of those Republicans happen to
be or excuse me, all of those governors happen to
be Republicans. So that's actually where we're
at right now, the only people in this country
that have surrendered to covid. Are those
Republican leaders who continue to surrender
to the nuttiest people in their states, the
most misinformed people in their states, we
have seen polls show that a majority of Americans
support mask mandates. Furthermore, polls have
also shown that a majority of Americans would be
OK with vaccine passports and vaccine mandates.
Even people who aren't vaccinated support
the vaccine passports, so we know there is
not a ton of disagreement about the fact
that we need to take care of each other.
But that hasn't stopped these Republican
governors, people like Rhonda Santurce,
Greg Abbott, Asa Hutchinson, all of them
have banned MASP mandates in their states.
And now we're also seeing massive
covid surges in the Republican
controlled state of Mississippi under
Republican Governor Tate Reeves. Reeves,
who came out the other day and actually said that
covid in kids is basically just the sniffles.
Less than 24 hours later, an eighth
grader in Mississippi died of covid.
Nobody has surrendered to covid except for
the Republicans, the Biden administration
has done a great job here in the United States
of getting vaccines out there. They have done a
great job of coming in and taking care of these
red states after they've had to admit, oh, no,
we can't handle it. We are sending 300 more
ventilators down here to the state of Florida
because our hospitals are overwhelmed over.
And I think it's Texas. They're, you know,
building these new covid beds in a parking
garage. Mississippi hospitals filling up, Alabama
hospitals filling up, Georgia hospitals filling
up, and of course, Texas and Florida seeing it to.
And Biden's been there every step of the way,
Biden has been supportive of the school districts
and counties that are defying these Republican
governors and putting mass mandates in place.
All that's left for Biden to do at this point
is make a nationwide mask mandate, which,
by the way, he already did for federally
funded forms of public transportation.
He has not surrendered to covid in the least.
The Republicans have their idiotic policies
followed with their idiotic talking points,
casting doubt about the effectiveness of the
vaccine, casting doubt about the effectiveness
of masks, that is what is fueling the covid surge
in the United States today. And none of that
is the fault of Joe Biden. That fault rests
on the shoulders of the Republicans who have
decided to politicize this pandemic. That is what
is going on in the United States today. And Trump
absolutely has just infuriated me, trying to
suggest otherwise. I am farand cousins, I'm
sitting in for David Pakman, we've got a lot more
wonderful stories coming up. And don't forget,
follow me on all my social media accounts at
Faran Balanced. We'll be right back with more